Oh
after watching the midseason finale of
The Walking Dead I'm still dumbfounded
as to why this remains one of TV's most
popular shows now I'm not gonna overly
bash it or fill my discussion with puns
like the boring dead do you see what I
did there but it has to be said that it
certainly feels that a show sent in
around walking has run out of Road
having been a fan from the star I was
overwhelmed with how good the first
season was it perfectly depicted a
post-apocalyptic world overrun by the
undead and possessed the human side
within that few shows have managed to
match like many fans I became enthralled
in the storyline and fell in love with
its characters and even though it's
struggled to maintain its quality I
stood by it like a parent who knows the
marriage isn't working but hangs around
for the kid
basically like Laurie in season 2
featuring a lackluster set of seasons
such as 4 5 & 6
many viewers decided to jump back on
board with season 7 after a heralded the
introduction of negan the new
cold-blooded killer with a bigger boner
for the bat than the Joker he was
legendary in the comics here a shake of
the show and alter the stale dynamics
potentially knocking it out of the park
however after critical panning and
outcry from fans it seems that the show
is struggling to recapture the love that
many viewers like myself once had I
believe this is down to the episode
formula of depicting an event and then
showing every characters perspective of
it over the course of six to eight
episodes no matter how uneventful or and
interesting it is upon the opening of
season 6 we saw the episode structure
break the mold and focus around the
group escorting zombies away from their
home in order to remain safe each
episode followed a different characters
view of the events and they helped to
build tension around the fate of Glenn a
beloved character that had mysteriously
disappeared during the outbreak working
expertly it eased his fate and became
the Schrodinger's cat of Reddit van't
theories on Izzi slash isn't he alive I
absolutely love this aesthetic and the
right has carried it off in such a way
that a kept viewers coming back time and
time again
seeking the answer to his end obviously
when something is this successful
creators and Studios want to replicate
it and like many TV shows The Walking
Dead has become a victim of its own
success blast forward to now and we get
the same episode structure but there is
about as much going on it's one of
Gabriel Sunday services what annoyed me
most about season eight was the fact
that it had been billed as all-out war
however when you look at the overarching
events very little has happened once
again focusing on a specific day from
multiple perspectives we are stuck
reliving the same moments over and over
with very little added to the overall
narrative the show has become Groundhog
Day what was so great about those
initial seasons is that the pace was so
fast that they should have called it the
running dead about shut up now okay a
promise we went from major event to
major event with no idea who would make
in who wouldn't time passed in the blink
of an eye and before we knew it the
survivors with shadows of their former
selves altered by the new world they
became macca valiant villains who would
move heaven and earth just to live
another day time within this world
allowed them to grow quicker than
Carol's hair and the show was better for
it by season 8 we see the same day from
different perspectives and whilst many
could argue that this actually helps the
audience intertwine with the characters
on a personal level I believe it does
the opposite stunting them within a
single moment the characters are unable
to really break free and evolve seeing
Rick attack negan's followers one
episode and Carol do the same the next
at a different camp
there's nothing overall for the story
and his ads repetitive beats that become
less exciting the more frequently they
happen I don't need to know what is
going on with Mackey as an attack is
being launched she is not a witness to
it I don't need to know about his écoles
forces being wiped out they are not
people I care about the show is pitted
as a battle between negan and Rick and
that should be its focus not the battle
before told in seven slightly different
ways fact of the matter is the last two
seasons could have been summed up in a
couple of episodes
Glenn dies the group becomes slaves they
break free negan goes down
that's it in season one and two the
tension between Rick and Shane was far
more palpable and anything that has
happened in season a and similar to this
I say that I'm doing the show seems to
just dot around the diatribe rather than
getting to the point I would love the
show to go back to a single unified
group living the event together as one
growing as a team it would allow us not
only to have a brisker story it would
also avoid the repetitiveness of seeing
the same moment from a different angle
imagine if there was a movie you watched
there enjoyed it and took everything
from it that you could would it not be a
waste of time to rewatch that movie shot
from a different camera angle with the
same beats and storyline that is what
the Walking Dead has become and why I
struggle to enjoy it I don't really see
how this show will end with a satisfying
conclusion and if it continues on this
path then it's walking's way to a dead
and look never mind
so in conclusion please write those show
as one event move on that's all I ask
for my sanity and for the sake of the
show please don't let us have a rotten
corpse as one of the most popular shows
on television I'm desperate for you to
give us a satisfying finale but I just
do not see how when you use this mold
that is going to be able to be
accomplished I really hope that you can
but I doubt it please bring it back to
life
if you want to survive yeah I'm not
proud of myself but thank you for
checking out my video essay on The
Walking Dead's perspective problems I
hope you enjoyed this video and if you
did please like it if you didn't
please dislike it and write a comment
yeah saying why you didn't because that
helped me out quite a lot and I really
appreciate you taking the time to put
some feedback into this I love it if you
subscribe to my channel as I'll do
videos like this all the time on movies
games TV and comics and if you want to
check out my website for the full
written review the links in the
description thanks very much take care
peace